[Music]
Christian
second
[Music]
yeah
for
[Music]
it's right
I'm
[Music]
Christian
e
[Music]
hello hello everyone how's everyone
doing how's everyone doing come on I
always want to get and say good morning
I just I'm so used to going to church in
the morning it's just one of these days
I'll say it and y'all will be like
weirdo um I want to welcome you all here
lots of new faces for me I haven't been
here in a couple weeks I I do a lot of
traveling so my name is miam for those
of you that I have not met would love to
say hi to you after this after the
service and stuff and meet you all um
but I wanted to welcome you to the table
happy to have you here it's getting a
little chilly Sweater Weather so
bringing out the flannel Jesse uh we've
got two quick announcements the first
one is next Sunday October 22nd is going
to be youth Sunday so if you're not
familiar with what that is essentially
our youth lead the service so they're
going to be you know prepping for that
um leading the service so our uh our
amazing teens will be doing that so
definitely show up and support them uh
during that time if you're able to and
then the other announcement I have
they've already got it up here but we
have a QR code now
um if you don't know what that is I'll
explain it in a second but essentially
what you can view with the QR code are
things like uh Spotify I think it's
Spotify I didn't even know we had that
to be honest our worship playlist um our
meetups um I would assume past sermons
all the good stuff uh all the good type
of stuff if you don't know what that is
all you do is you take your camera as
I'm putting my phone away you take your
camera and you hold it up to the QR code
and it'll display a link click on that
and then you're good to go ask any
Millennial or jenz in here and they'll
be able to help you um staring at you
all right those are the announcements I
have um I'm going to lead us into into
worship with Mindy and the team um I
just want you all to kind of settle your
hearts and your minds if you've come in
into this Sunday service I know like me
with a little bit of anxiety with kind
of what's going on in the world today
just settle your hearts and your minds
and really realize that we're all here
together as a family we all love each
other um we're all here to worship the
same God and you know be in communion
with each other um so if you don't mind
bowing your heads in prayer with me I'll
lead us in
worship God first and foremost I thank
you for everyone that is here tonight um
I thank you for their hearts and the
love that they have for one another and
for our community um grateful that
everyone made it here safely I pray that
as I just said that we're
all able to open our hearts and Minds
towards um Brett and the sermon tonight
um I know it's going to be a special one
something that I've been eager to hear
about um so I'm excited for everyone to
be able to join in on that I pray that
if anyone in this room is going through
anything specific um that again you just
hold them in your arms and you remind
them that we're here for them as well
and you're here for them and that they
utilize a people people around them and
know that they are loved and that they
are cherished and that they are wanted
it's in Jesus name that I pray
amen thanks Miriam well you guys go
ahead and stand with us um if this is
your first time we open up our service
with some worship and it's a space for
all of us to join together it's not a
performance um it's an all play and we
would love for you guys to sing if if
you know the song sing along if you
don't you're welcome to just soak it in
to clap to move around the room stay
seated um it's a free space and our
first song that we're singing tonight is
about freedom and I was just thinking
about some of the recent events that
have been announced um last week we were
talking about the war that's breaking
out with Israel I know there's been some
stuff going on here locally um like with
the state fair and some disputes and um
I just my heart tonight is that we would
move in the opposite spirit of fear that
we would not be a people who are moving
in Strife um in opposition to one
another but a people who lead the way in
peace and um and when we have peace
there's Freedom there so let's enjoy the
freedom that Community brings um and the
and more than that the freedom that the
spirit of Christ brings in us um this is
Jesse and Caleb and Caitlyn and Josh and
I'm Mindy and we're just really glad
that you guys are with with us tonight
so let's sing together and um yeah fill
this space up with some with some
creativity some beauty um some
truth let's sing amen
together
aen
[Music]
am amen let's sing that one more time
aen
[Music]
amen
amen oh falling down like great love
that I can't explain a peace Thats My
[Music]
Soul light in the darkest Place life
even in the pain it feels like coming
home where the spirit where the spirit
of the Lord is there is
freedom I am free
amen amen where the spirit of the Lord
is there is
freedom I am free
and here I'm alive again God is the we
of sin oh sweet
Liberty oh Lord praise God who saved my
life I'm with the blood of Christ I have
been
redeemed where the spirit of the Lord is
there is freedom
I am
free where the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom I am free anden let's sing that
again where the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom I am free
amen amen where the spirit of the Lord
is there is
freedom I am free
amen let's sing it out free at last free
at last thank God Almighty I am free at
last all my chains are in the past
thank
[Music]
godmy I am free at last sing it again
free at last free at last thank God
Almighty I am free
last all my chains are in the past thank
God Almighty I am
free one more time
free at last free at last thank God
Mighty I am free
andless all my chains are in in the past
thank God Almighty I am
free
yeah I'm free oh I am free sing where
the spirit the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom I am free
amen where the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom am free
amen one more time where the Spirit of
the Lord is there is
freedom I am free
am where the spirit of the Lord is there
is
freedom I am
free all right love hearing 's voices
kiddos are dismissed we have our older
kids right here in this room so second
through sixth grade and then we have um
four years old through first grade over
here to my
left and thank you kids ministry workers
thank you so much for loving on our kids
I know Britney and Maggie Kelly August
Eve
L um can't remember who's in the back
today but nursery workers we love
you thank you guys so much much and
we're going to go ahead and transition
into the prayers of the people and this
is just a prayer that we like to pray
together to make space for the things
that we are carrying into this room each
week um we know that life is not without
pain and struggle and we want to make
space for that so we will read this
prayer aloud together and then um we're
going to leave some space for you to
lift up whatever you're caring so speak
out a name or a situation that might be
on your heart tonight and um we'll just
leave a couple minutes for that and then
if you're online with us you're welcome
to leave that in the comments um and we
like to read through those and and just
know that you're with us here in this
space even even if you are virtually
with us and then we'll close out the
prayer together again at the end so
would you guys join me in praying for
this city of saxi Texas and for every
city and community and all who live in
them we pray to you for the Good Earth
that you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you
Chelsea
Johnny James
Clarissa
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence
amen
[Music]
oh how can I re
respond to the love that you have
lavished
on
me how can I
respond to the love that you have
lavished
on
me I don't have
much I don't have
much but I have a heart that beats for
you I have a heart that beats for you I
don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for
[Music]
you
every part of
me want to love you like you love
me
Lord every part of
me want to love you like you love
me my
Lord I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for
I have a heart that beats for you I have
a heart that beats for you I have a
heart thats for you I have a heart thats
for you I have a heart that for you I
have a life I'll give to you I have a
life I'll give to you I have a life I'll
give to you I have a life I'll give to
you I have a heart that beats for you I
have a heart that beats for you I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for
you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
for you and I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for
[Music]
you
God in the midst of the chaos around
us in the midst of
struggle or confusion or
stress God we speak
peace and we speak
blessing God would we receive your
blessing in our
lives
[Music]
Lord bless
you and keep
you make his face shine upon you and be
gracious to you Lord turn
his face toward
you and give you peace
[Music]
amen
amen the Lord bless
you and keep
you make his face shine upon you and be
Gra
to you the Lord turn
his face toward
you and give you
peace sing it out
amen
and
amen am amen
[Music]
amen
amen sing it
again
amen am
amen
[Applause]
[Music]
amen may his favor be upon you and and a
thousand
generations and your family and your
children and their children and their
children may his presence go before you
and behind you and inside you all around
you and within you he's with you he's
with you in the morning in the evening
and your coming
and you're weeping and rejoicing he's
with you he's for you he is for you he
is for you he is for you he's for you he
is for you he's for
[Music]
you
amen
anden
[Music]
amen
am
amen may his favor be upon you and a
thousand
generations and your family and your
children and their children and their
children
may his presence go before you and
behind you and beside you all around you
and within you he's with you he's with
you in the morning in the evening and
you're coming and you're going and
you're weeping and
rejoicing he is for you he is for you he
is for you he is for you he's for you
he's for you he's for you he's for
[Music]
you
amen
[Music]
amen let's just lift our
voices last
time
a
[Music]
amen God we sing amen may it be
so may you bring
[Music]
blessing where your spirit is there is
freedom where your spirit it is there is
unity and peace there is forgiveness and
Redemption and
hope there is light that is stronger
than
Darkness there is love that is stronger
hate there is healing where there has
been pain and injury and
abuse God would we be light bearers
would we be peace
[Music]
Bringers would we bring the spirit of
Christ with us into our homes into our
workplaces and our schools and our
world would we bring
blessing would we Speak
[Music]
Life
because you are good and you have not
given up on
us you are with us you are for
us and we sink ourselves into that truth
tonight we thank you for it in Jesus
name
amen thank you guys for worshiping
together with us would you turn to the
people around you make them feel welcome
introduce yourself if you don't know
them then Brett will get us
started well Grace and peace it is so
good to be with you all so good good and
um that uh that was a that was a
beautiful meaningful time I I love those
um closing lines uh he is for you God is
for you God is for you God is for you I
love the repetition sometimes we need
that um because we don't believe it the
first or second or third time we need it
driven home and uh and I really do
believe that's a word um for someone
maybe multiple someone's tonight um that
the Lord Jesus is for you and loves you
so um my name is Brett I'm just really
really glad to be here with you all and
uh that as always includes those joining
us online y'all are not forgotten and um
and also anyone here who is new tonight
thank you for being here I know it can
um it can just be a lot walking through
those doors it just can like you don't
know anyone and just wondering what the
heck is this place about and um and no
matter what the website says you know
it's like well they say they say they're
welcoming and inclusive and blah blah
you know I mean but yeah but what does
that mean really you know um it's just
it is it's just a lot and so um I want
you to know that you're we're really
grateful that you're here and um thank
you for pushing through and uh yeah just
being Among Us so um this is uh let's
see we're in week three right now we
kind of tend to do series here at the
table so um week three of a series but
they're all a standalone message so you
haven't like you know you won't be lost
or something
and uh we've been covering these phrases
so the the title of the series is the
Bible doesn't say that and it's it's for
all those little sayings that are like
floating around in culture um also
sometimes in the church that uh like it
sounds kind of biblical
eishes you know but uh but it's not
actually found in the Bible and so and
now sometimes there it's sort of like um
well it's sort of I would say there's
been a sliding scale of kind of the
truth of of them I'm not saying
necessarily like every phrase we've
mentioned this series just the worst
thing ever and you know although much of
the time I am doing a critique that's
certainly true of the one tonight um but
it's sort of a slight scale you know at
times it's sort of there's truth in it
but like any cliche you know I mean well
that's the nature of like little Plucky
sayings little aphorisms you know like
it lacks Nuance you know and um and
regardless of the Nuance often the way
it the way these phrases are used you
know sort of like well maybe there's a
time and a place um but uh we often kind
of misuse them you know so it's things
like um week one was like God has a
wonderful plan for your life you know
and our point there wasn't like no he
doesn't um it was it was just simply
like you know what happens when life
breaks down though you know it's like
well is this the plan you know so you
can see where it's just at times these
little sayings they're clunky and
they're you know it's It's Tricky so um
this week the the phrase we're looking
at and the title of the message is is
it's a juicy
one love the
sinner hate the sin oh man Collective
moan there's like the collective uh
Collective sigh I know and I think my my
guess is the reason there's such a maybe
I don't know there could be some folks
are like oh this seems like a fine
phrase um the the reason for that
Collective moan is again I would say
it's the way this has been used which
we'll get more into I'll get into a
pretty heavy critique of this phrase um
as we kind of get into the message um
especially how this this one um has been
kind of used often against folks who are
gay lesbian bisexual transgender you
know and so on um which is that's a
that's a tricky application even like
even if I were you know not an affirming
person or something like I would still
say I wouldn't even use this phrase just
because like that's the whole point
they're like this isn't a sin like I
this is just who I am you know what I
mean but so when you use it in that way
you know I mean somebody uses it in that
way well I love you anyway you know it's
just you can see where it's just
incredibly problematic so this this
phrase in particular probably among all
all of them has been deployed in really
you know painful ways for a lot of folks
so I acknowledge that but what I what I
start with I want to pretend as best we
can it's impossible let's pretend like
we've never heard it like you know
that's like the ti of message is love
the sinner hate the sin you know I mean
here's a few things I think I'm going to
be as charitable as I can I think the
things that has going for it gosh darn
it it is just memorable as all out like
you hear it one time it forever just
implanted you I mean it's so poetic so
catchy like got the three words love the
sinner hate the S I mean it's just
balanc good poetry you know just like
gez very it is it's very memorable
um the also I I think it's
um like well here's the way I want to
draw from um there's a little there's I
because I think there's helpful ways to
to deploy this so there's a Calvin and
Hobs cartoon strip maybe some of youall
have seen this one I think what's tricky
or it's interesting here is Calvin's
directing against himself for those who
aren't familiar Calvin Hobs is like an
old comic strip all the the young people
in here never heard of Calvin and Hobbs
um but Calvin's just a troublemaker so
the in the strip you can see if we have
it up on the screen where Calvin's
holding this sign with this completely
freaked out look love the centner hate
the sin and then of course his dad's
getting home from work with a briefcase
uhoh you know like what does this mean
and uh I think it's this is funny
because I mean it's interesting that
here Calvin's directing it against
himself you know that's what's kind of
tricky though with this phrase is you
could like I could imagine a world like
for example where in my worst moments
I've like messed up like sin you know
call what whatever you want but I've
messed it up I could imagine a world in
which I'm like holding up a sign like
that like honey please you know love the
sinner hate the in other words can you
please see somehow a difference between
sort of what I this stupid thing I have
done you know and who I am my identity
um the way Richard Beck who's a
wonderful Christian writer and
psychologist out of um abalene Christian
University he wrote actually a book I'm
drawing quite heavily from we did a
whole series on it like a year ago the
book's titled unclean and this message
is very much I just when I heard this
statement I immediately thought of his
book so for those who are here for that
series you'll like hear Echo of some of
his thought but the way he has a blog
post where he's talking about this topic
and he says you know I mean kind of if
you take it kind of disconnect it
divorce it from its actual usage in the
church this is a it's a pretty clever
little summary of two kind of Christian
theological ideas love and Holiness
that's in essence like you could see it
in that way you know where love The
Sinner right like yeah okay love and
then you know hate the sin
you know AKA actually I know even the
word Holiness has some baggage with it
but it's just you know if we think of it
as just a love in a pursuit of the good
that which is good that which is in
alignment with God's heart like I mean
who would who would disagree you know I
mean like yes we want to be in alignment
with what God is about and so again
imagining you've never heard this we
could kind of think like oh that's
that's clever um you know love the
sinner hate the sin okay okay um has
promise and yet yet and yet boy for all
of its promise and
its its
poetry it has just it just failed it did
it just failed to
deliver
the
theological
discipleship Goods it's like uh use
Sports metaphors it's like Russell
Wilson joining the Denver
Broncos sorry I know Jesse's a big it's
like this is my second statement which I
did is in my notes Jesse he's a big
Broncos fan it's like the Dallas Cowboys
for the last 25 years so much hype so
much
promise and yet in the end utter
disappointment you know uh that I want
to contend that in essence is what love
the sin or hate the sin um it's just not
it's just underperformed it's not lived
up to the hype and this of course begs
the question but but why you know again
trying to be charitable like so much
promise it's so clever you know why did
it fail so badly I this is what um well
I want to focus on two words I think
it's the word Sinner and hate I think
that's the thing that this is where we
it's it started getting
sideways um so let's like I think in
essence what happens is you take those
right they're in separate parts parts of
the phrase even um but somehow I think
those two words sinner hate sinner hate
they burrow down into our minds and
there
[Music]
merge and we end up uh in a bad place so
let's talk about these these words all
right sinner is the first one sinner you
know who um you know who did not use the
term sinner very
often Jesus
isn't that kind of interesting like I
don't know it's such a churchy word you
know what I mean like sinner Sinners I I
think maybe it's because we talk a lot
about Sin you know doing wrong but
actually Jesus didn't use the word
sinner uh much at all you know who loved
the term
sinner the Pharisees the religious
leaders of the day they were like all
about it they were big fans they liked
this um and so even if if you think of
like well I've read the Bible the New
Testament it's there a lot often it's
actually the Pharisees who were using it
in fact I I went back I just started
researching like every time Jesus used
the word sinner what I noticed was um
over and over and over he uses it not a
lot not like a 100 times he's I don't
know probably seven eight times but if
you kind of pay attention to the context
he's um almost always it's in context
where he's he's speaking with someone
else usually a religious person
themselves who they are using the word
and so he uses it as he's conversing
with them right what he doesn't do
you'll never find him for example
preaching a sermon to the masses and
saying all right all you
Sinners get your lives right you know um
that's you don't you don't find that um
instead he he uses it when other people
use it I'll give you a few um examples
so this is there's of course the way the
gospels right Matthew Mark Luke John
often tell the same stories from
slightly different perspective slightly
different version but it's like the same
story so this one you can find in
Matthew 9:13 Luke 532 to Mark 2:17 kind
of same story played out in different
ways so the um one of the practices
Jesus was really well known for was um
what's known as table
Fellowship uh which is basically the his
practice he would enter the home and eat
with uh basically anyone
and he would have anyone into his place
um in the kind of 21st century this is a
bit lost on us we we don't uh it's it's
not quite as big a deal although it is
still kind of a big deal you know what I
mean like we do have certain boundaries
and who's welcomed into the home you
know and there is something kind of
vulnerable about a home it's like you
keep that door you got that door you
know in the lock and the as long as
they're on the outside you're safe you
know but you you let them in in an act
of hospitality and it's sort of like or
you go inside you know so Jesus was well
known for this I mean the the the way
the scriptures talk about it is he would
um eat with um Tax
Collectors uh uh prostitutes and sinners
this is the kind of language of the New
Testament for who Jesus was known for
eating with and as often the language of
the Pharisees is what they would say so
in the story they actually
um they go and talk to well it's the
Pharisees go to Jesus disciples which is
kind of interesting they don't go to
Jesus they go to his disciples and they
basically ask him um
why why is he doing this why why and I
don't know if the situations like where
Jesus is right there that's what it
seems to be in the context which you'll
see in just a moment it seems like Jesus
is very close by I think it's a passive
aggressive move I think like why does he
keep doing this you know like like where
you're speaking here but you're really
talking to Jesus I don't because it's
odd that Jesus is the one who responds
so they're speaking the disciples and
then Jesus is right so they basically
why does he just Why does he eat with
tax collectors Sinners prostitut you
know
Etc and uh Jesus of course overhears
them and uh verse 12 of Matthew 9 on
hearing this Jesus said well it is not
the healthy who need a doctor but the
sick which is interesting that he
changes the metaphor a little bit
but go and learn what this means now
he's preaching to him he's a no
shrinking violet Jesus is no shrinking
violet go and learn what this means I
desire Mercy not sacrifice for I have
not come to call the righteous but
Sinners can you see where he uses it
there's the word Sinners said it but can
you see the
context right they're like why do you
why are you doing like he's he's using
it because they use it it he's not
preaching a sermon at people and finger
pointing all you you that's not the
context
um another quick example this is from um
Luke 15 the disciples are traveling with
Jesus and they ask him it seems to be it
was like news of the day there was this
Tower of Siloam and apparently there was
some sort of accident they were
constructing this Tower and famously it
fell we don't know a lot of details
except what the New Testament tells us
and apparently it crushed some of the
workers when it fell it's like this
tragedy
so the disciples asked
Jesus uh did that Tower fall on those
people because they're worse Sinners
than everyone else that's what they ask
and so Jesus basically responds in in
short he just says no he's like no not
because they're worse Sinners than other
people and he kind of goes on from there
so again he uses the term use the word
Center but can you see in context he's
often um he's using it differently he's
using in conversation with people who
themselves um are using it so so while
the word center it's certainly it's
there it's in the Bible Jesus himself
used it very rarely and notably in
keeping with our series he never ever
said love The Sinner or love those
Sinners uh Jesus never said that instead
do you know what his preferred term
was uh I think this is instructive for
us as a church his preferred term was
neighbor isn't that a better term I I
think that's a better term and and of
course when he uses this he doesn't
literally mean like your neighbor like
the people to your left that live next
to you like in America in the suburbs or
you know whatever um instead but he
means uh you know those kind of In Your
Circle of Care those the people around
you which Jesus Circle of Care the way
he taught his disciples was that that
Circle just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and until really all
the world is who your neighbor every
person you interact with is your
neighbor um can you see that's like a
totally different emotional tone that
that word right see everyone around you
good and bad alike as neighbors as yes
people who sin but people who sin just
like me right that's it's not some
difference it's it's uh see everyone as
a precious child of God a person to be
loved this is a a tremendous um
difference so I guess this in of itself
kind of begs the question why was this
Jesus preferred term here I'm
speculating a little bit my hunches I
just I think he knew
like I think he knew his own culture
right he's familiar with the Pharisees
and kind of religion sort of getting
sideways and he knew our weaknesses he
knew our vulnerabilities and he knew
that this language of Sinner even just
in his own day and you can see where
it's played out in our in ours today um
just it got sideways it got problematic
it it became um very kind of us in them
like one way to to frame it here I'm
drawing on Richard Beck um this is the
idea of Holiness in love
pull in opposite
directions it's only by grace that we
can merge them and I do think they
should be merge I'm not saying like so
you know hly is love they pull off dire
so choose love and forget Holiness I'm
not saying that but this is kind of what
I mean um when if you think of Holiness
right Holiness sort of um orienting your
whole life heart mind soul body to God
right bringing yourself into utter
alignment with the good that God is um
can you see where that if you keep kind
of going in that direction and thinking
in that framework you tend to distance
yourself from
who yeah neighbors slash for our
purposes Sinners you know what I mean
because well this kind of comes back to
the whole reason the Pharisees were
freaked out by Jesus table Fellowship
like hey don't you know those people
that's sin is um it's
contagious you know it's it it gets on
you it it's um it it d RS desires can be
contagious and so you got to you got to
be careful Jesus right can you see where
a real deep commitment to Holiness even
if it's well-intentioned like I'm not
assuming that's necessarily bad like in
in essence a drive for Holiness I'm not
saying that's bad but can you see where
that starts to distance you from others
because you want to stay on the
righteous path um so then what does love
do this is why I say they pull an
opposite opposite directions because
love always does what draws near comes
close moves
close and then closer and then closer
can can you see that so this is kind of
the the trick I'd say of Christian
Theology and this is why this statement
was tricky and ultimately didn't work
out is because Holiness and love it's
attention it's and this is why I say
it's only by the grace and goodness of
God that we kind of
ultimately live into this and somehow by
God's goodness merge the two somehow
find a place where we can say hey
Holiness Matters How I Live matters
being oriented towards the good being
oriented towards Christ Living like
Christ like all the things absolutely
that matters without doing what
distancing distancing and then what
comes with the distancing
judging and before you know it you know
those you're wagging your finger at the
Sinners you know
while proclaiming the God who is
love is can you see where it just it all
gets
scrambled um and I I think ultimately
this is some of the problem with love
the sin or hate the sin it's those two
words Sinner and hate um sinner it's a
term of
identity um right they're not just a
person who has shortcomings like me
struggles with sin like me no no they're
a dirty unclean person they're a sinner
and of course that just like we named
that plays on the Holiness thing and
then you add that to the word hate
hatred I hate their sin I hate their sin
I'm I'm worked up about their sin I'm
upset about their sin and and this is
you know but this is what God wants me
to do I'm so upset about them and theirs
and I'm obsessed with it you know can
you see where it's
like
huh
what like it's it's sort of the opposite
of the Calvin Hobs cartoon strip where
he's putting it back on himself you know
hey please show some Grace you know
that's completely different than when we
start deploying this on
others now you might say what I'm not
going to get ugly or upset or I'm not
GNA obsess over their sin I'm just you
know but there're Sinners I still have
to kind of treat them as you know I
think even kind of in the best of ways
um
this ends
up again
distancing this hatred and obsession
with another sin ends up um kind of
burrowing down into us and I imagine it
kind of like chewing up whatever love
was there and then spitting it out in
essence I think the word love in the
statement love the sin or hate the sin
ends up getting eaten you know and as
since we start out trying to do both we
say I'm going to I'm going to thread the
needle I'm going to love people and I'm
going to hate their sin all at the same
time but what happens we just end up
hating
them like that's the endgame it just
it's just human nature um chews it up
spits it out and I think um in this you
can see with that obsession with another
sin who sin suddenly are we not so
focused on in that our own like can you
see where suddenly this is why I say
this phrase has become so toxic not just
because it's like well that hurts people
you know yes that's part of it but also
it becomes bad for us for the very
person saying it because instead of like
true Holiness is very interested in in
my own heart and mind in how I'm doing
you know like Lord I'm thinking of the
psalmist you know create in me a clean
heart oh God you know not create in them
a clean heart oh God do a miracle
they're so messed up you know how messed
up they are God and like suddenly all
your prayers are about them and their
sins and their shortcomings and their
Pro it's no there there's something here
I just I suspect it's a
way at least eventually if we use it too
much eventually I swear it becomes a way
of of getting the attention off of us
and honestly that kind of feels good
like in a way you know it's take the
spotlight off of me and put it onto the
I don't know the messed upness of others
and that's like a little boost you know
like um and and even maybe a way I could
say this is in the end
um this statement it just reeks of
self-righteousness love the sin or hate
the sin like even if even at its
best it just does it just reeks of hey
you're really messed
up
but I'm going to love you
anyway just like like the most humble
brag of all you know just like what
that's right I'm I'm that
gracious I am you know it's just yeah it
just doesn't work it doesn't work so
what
um what does work I want to come back to
love love draws near pushes through
societal boundaries and
warnings draws
near Rowan Williams the uh the church
leader um Christian wonderful wonderful
Church leader and Christian he said this
failure in other words like the failures
of sins the shortcomings of others
failure is only
healed by
humility and
solidarity not by condemnation wa is
that not true for all of us that I mean
the minute even if I know I'm like
messed up or wrong or you know whatever
but if someone's like you're so messed
up you know I mean I like am defensive
like even if the back of my mind I'm
like yeah probably but I'm just like nuh
you know I mean digging in my heels and
how you're judgmental and you know like
you get nowhere with that you get
nowhere like what's what changes us it's
like when people see us in just all of
just who we are you know our struggle
our mess and they're like hey I've been
there I've been there maybe even not in
that exact same way or that exact thing
or you know but like I've been there
we've all been there how healing is that
how beautiful is
that I'll close with the story there was
a um a desert father his name was um he
had a few names ABA Moses um ABA uh uh
ABA Moses the the black in the Ethiopian
he was um a desert father from like the
fourth Century famous Saint um red in
like early Christian writings like
Reed uh true Saint you know and even
it's not even like a saint that they
kind of 500 years later they're like
well that person was a saint it's like
his peers said that man's a saint he was
amazing um but there's this story that
was passed down about him apparently
there was um a brother in his town the
town of skus uh where that that would it
doesn't say what he did but this brother
this Christian brother he messed up he
did something something bad bad enough
that a kind of local Council Church
Council was called to like kind of pass
judgment on this this man and so the
priests and the bishop and and folks
wanted ABA Moses there um so they
invited him and um you know what he did
he turned them down he said nope not
going so a few days passes finally the
day of the actual Council comes they
really want him there so the priest
sends kind of a underling you know
whatever like hey go go get him they go
to AB Mo's house and they say um hey the
priest is it's the council's about to
start they would really appreciate if
you could be there and
surprisingly uh AA Moses agreed but he
got this large this giant jug this is in
the desert so um giant jug and filled it
like with water about as much as he
could drag but this jug had cracks in it
and so what he did was he dragged this
jug through the town it's making like a
muddy mess all behind him he drags The
Jug all the way to the the council and
he gets there and all of the leaders go
out to greet him and they are completely
puzzled they're just like so glad you're
here but your jug has a crack in it and
you've made a muddy mess and this is
what AA Moses said he said Brothers my
own
sins flow out behind me like water all
day and I'm not even aware of them
and yet you invite me here to pass
judgment on
another The Story Goes that they
immediately canel the
counsel and forgave the
brother when I think of who we are
called to
be I think of that
story
gracious
patient humble standing in solidarity
with people in their own struggles as we
have
ours not called to pass judgment and
distance so I wonder if um maybe we
could just shorten the statement you
know instead of love the sinner hate the
sin maybe we could just be
love
I I think that would give us more than
enough to work
on in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen so as we come to the table of the
Lord tonight as we take in the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
in the wine um we do so as a people in
need we do so as a people in solidarity
with one another do we come down this
aisle and receive the body the blood of
Jesus Christ we we come as simultaneous
Sinners and Saints which is the Paradox
of for each of us in our own living like
there's parts of us that are just
beautiful and just like Jesus and then
there's the other parts and so we we
come to receive this um in that kind of
heart posture tonight so the way um
we'll we'll take communion is uh we just
go row by row we'll start the front and
we'll just kind of work work our way
back um everyone is welcome to
participate but there's no pressure If
you're in a place where you're like I
don't know you know if I'm even a
Christian or something okay that's you
know we're not making you on the other
hand if there's anything in you that you
say I don't know if I have all the right
theology or beliefs or whatever
denomination yall are you know but um I
but something in me wants to connect
with the Risen Christ well then just
know you are you welcome here um at this
table um you should know the red is WI
the white is grape juice so you've been
warned it's a rude awakening if you take
the um and then finally you can just
partake whenever you'd like no one will
like come up and Lead You Through the
moment of you know you can just you can
take it immediately you could return to
your seat and have kind of a prayerful
moment and take just however you'd like
to do it so this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you you who have much faith and you who
have little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long you
who have tried to
follow and you who have
failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
table
for
[Music]
we're going to close out our service
tonight with um a new song and um the
chorus is very simple it's very easy to
catch on to so I want to invite you guys
to stand with us if you're comfortable
doing that and um as you learn it um the
word is just May the peace of the Lord
go with you and um I just felt like in
the spirit of moving towards uh love and
connection and away from division and
judgment and othering and
separation um I just wanted us to speak
this out over each other and take this
with us into our week um so let's
Jesse's G to lead this one and you guys
just follow along um and join in
whenever you pick it
[Music]
up
May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace peace of the Lord go
with you May the peace of the Lord go
with
you
wherever you may
go if he sends you to the
[Music]
wild may he give you
flowing spring
[Music]
through the long
days of your
Exodus taste the sweetness the man
brings May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace peace of the Lord go
with
you
wherever you may
go if he sends you on the
reny May his Mercy go
before to show you where you're calling
B and protect you in the
storm May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you wherever wherever you may
[Music]
go if he sends you through the veil of
Tears may he join you as You
[Music]
Weep may he hold
you when you meet your
fears in the sh
who's dark and
[Music]
deep May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you
wherever you may make
go
wherever you may
[Music]
go um I want to say thank you to the
worship team and to Brett um for such a
wonderful message I had mentioned in the
beginning of the service that I was
excited to hear this message um
specifically because that phrase is
something I've been recently
trying test there we go that I've been
trying to kind of unravel with my
therapist I've never I I I can't I
couldn't put figure out why it bothered
me so
much um just very quickly when I came
out a couple of years ago I had a very
close friend of mine who whom I would
consider a best friend came out to and
the first thing he said to me was ah
Miriam hate this sin Love The Sinner and
I was like ooh that doesn't feel good
but because I love this person right I
want this person to be in my life and
for a couple of years now two years now
I've been trying to unravel what why
does that not sit well with me and I
think Brett did a wonderful job
explaining it um words can hurt just as
much if not more than they can heal
sometimes so I encourage all of us to
you know be mindful
of what we're saying of what we're
hearing um myself included right and
just make sure that what we say lifts
people up rather than brings them
down um I want to thank all of you for
joining us this evening again especially
if you're new we know how hard it can be
walking through those doors it's a scary
and intimidating experience but know
that you're welcome and you're loved and
that we'd love to chat with you
afterwards um come find me or really
anybody um come chat with us uh we'd
love to know if you are new so we do
have little cards out there on the table
or that QR code um if you scan that QR
code up there uh let us know who you are
uh we'd love to just um you know
acknowledge that you are here and
welcome you um if you are in need of a
prayer a hug or just generally just want
to talk uh say hi find me find Brett
find anyone um after the service and
we'd love to give that to you here at
the table we are committed to creating
an inclusive Christ Center community
that touches lives and generosity from
us all of us um is the pivotal thing in
doing so so if you feel led to support
us financially you can scan again this
QR code makes it very simple you don't
have to waste any paper or uh go online
TBL tx.org theable tx.org or again there
are the cards out in the hallway that
you could fill out to do so from there
last but not least I want to send you
all out with a benediction for the week
so if you would like to you could stand
in a posture of receiving close your
eyes or just listen to the words as they
say them to you here oh
sorry you are a child of God you are a
child of God and this is true on your
best day and it's especially true on
your worst day so as you go into your
week ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted just the way that you
are and go filled with God's holy spirit
in the desire to extend these same Gifts
of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone that you come in contact with I
hope you all are blessed and we hope to
see you next week remember it's the
youth Sunday so make sure you're here to
support them through that thanks
everyone
May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you
where you may
go where
go